There's been a lot of talk over the past
few years.
Um,
and in some popular books about the
power of intuition and how if we trust
that our intuitions or went with our
guts more often,
we would actually wind up making better
decisions in the world would even be a
better place.
Some researchers have talked about how
our intuitions and the intuitive
judgments we can make,
the snap judgements are actually
accurate a lot of the time.
And a lot of that is true.
But what we noticed when thinking about
our gorilla experiment and doing
research for this book is that there's a
whole category of intuitions that are
actually systematically wrong and in
very dangerous ways.
And those are the intuitions we have
about how our own minds work.
So the gorilla experiment shows that we
intuitively think that we pay attention
to a notice much more than we actually
do.
And that can have tragic consequences if
you get into a car accident or at one of
the examples in our book is a nuclear
submarine that surfaced right into a
Japanese fishing boat because in part
the captain of the submarine looked up
in the periscope,
didn't see any boats around and surface
right into one that he didn't see.
That was actually probably right in
front of him.
So there's a case where intuitively we
think something and it can really get us
into big trouble.
We realized as we were thinking about
the book and putting together the idea
is that this category of intuitions is
very broad.
It's not just about visual attention,
it's also about memory.
We think we remember things much more
accurately than we really do.
I,
it's about confidence.
We think that people who are confident
are also more skilled and accurate and
knowledgeable.
It's about our own knowledge.
We think that we know and understand
more about the world and we really do
and so on.
They're sort of like a whole sort of set
of these intuitions which,
um,
can really lead us astray if we're not
aware of them.
And that's what we decided to write the
book about.
We are in a way,
taking on the impression that a lot of
people have from books like blink by
Malcolm Gladwell and others in that
category,
which is sort of an uncritical belief in
the power of intuition and snap
judgments and so on.
And the idea that,
um,
you should rely on them whenever
possible.
Um,
we sort of are,
uh,
in a sense taking on the cult of
intuition or the myth of intuition as we
call it in the book.
I should also say that we're very
pleased at Malcolm gladwell actually
read our original scientific journal
Article about the invisible gorilla
study and talked about it and one of his
New Yorker articles,
which helped it get more publicity and
ultimately led to it becoming more
widely known,
uh,
and as famous as it is.